his awareness of the ring space was
clear now he could hear the echoes of it
in the fabric of reality like he was
pressing his ear to a ship's deck to
know the status of its drive the rage of
the enemy was apparent to him now as he
could hear its voices the shrieks that
tore something that wasn't air in
something that wasn't time hey guys pete
here as you probably know the pre-order
is ongoing for the final book of the
expanse series leviathan falls and now
when you go to the order page you can
click the cover to look inside and read
the first four chapters it's not a lot
but there is a surprising amount of
things to talk about in this little
tease i'm gonna do that today but first
i have to give you a spoiler warning if
you haven't read all of the expanse
novels then this video isn't for you i'm
gonna talk about things that you won't
be able to unhear and i suggest you take
this chance to leave and go start
reading instead with that out of the way
let's get started
leviathan falls is listed as 528 pages
which is about 40 pages shorter than the
average but they're all about the same
and it doesn't seem very important it
has one of the best dedications you can
hope for while waiting for something
like this to come to an end scrolling
down i definitely stopped on that and
felt something it has a complete dust
jacket blurb and i will come back to
that because it gives away some things
that aren't touched on in the chapters
the sample gives us three chapters with
three povs and a one-off from the
prologue which has been pretty
consistent over the series it's hard to
say how many povs total we can expect
but the other two books in this trilogy
had a ton and i'm guessing we'll see
that continue rather than what they did
earlier in the series first we have jim
noticeably not holden which is how his
chapters were always titled in the past
that seems important so we'll definitely
talk about that aliana tanika who is a
colonel in the laconian marine corps she
played a role in persepolis rising and
it is nice to see her come back and then
we also get a chapter from naomi who
after the events of book 8 is the
functional leader of the underground as
for the prologue guess who's back the
high council of laconia is back at least
sort of the opening lines of this first
book first there was a man named winston
duarte and then there wasn't beg the
question of what remains to take the
man's place it's a question i've been
thinking about for a couple of years and
there are some hints if not answers in
the prologue as we flash back to the
time before this threw me for a bit of a
loop because the novels don't usually
open with a recap that made it thrilling
to realize that they were actually
recounting duarte's mind being blown
apart like a pile of straw and then it's
coming back together it had been clear
that duarte had been changing into
something else ever since cortazar
started giving him the protomolecule
treatments he had new enhanced senses
and other side effects and was even
starting to grow new internal organs he
was becoming something else and i think
of cortazar saying not dead becoming
back in season two duarte was becoming
something half human and half
protomolecule it's interesting to get
some insight into how his mind was
working before it wasn't and i do wonder
if his scrambling during the unknown
aggressor's counter-attack after tacoma
set him up to come back as something
even more adorable in visiting admiral
trejo we see that he at least picked up
a new tool and i just have to say i feel
for trejo here ever since the god
emperor was reduced to his shuffling and
slobbering self trejo's been working
overtime trying to keep things together
only to get a thanks but you know what i
don't really need you anymore i got this
but this ability to kind of just show up
places it's very similar to what the
proto-molecule did with holden and the
investigator and if nothing else shows
that the new duarte is in sync with the
gate builders in their tech possibly in
a way we haven't seen before
proto miller was a completely different
situation his consciousness was absorbed
into the project on eros while his body
was broken down and repurposed for
whatever was needed in building the ring
gate the connected proto-molecule was
manipulating holden's brain so that he
saw someone that he recognized amos cara
and xan are different still they all
died and were put back together by the
repair drones they have a connection
with the library as a result and it's
not really clear how much of them is
still human in some senses they're
frozen in time kara and zan still look
the same as they did they never grew
into adulthood and they're not affected
by the attacks in the same way duarte
was he was a living human who was
enhanced by the treatments it made him
vulnerable to those attacks but not as
vulnerable as the gate builders
themselves the fact that he came back
makes it seem possible that now he might
be more gate builder than human that is
if the scales were tipped the other way
before and his comment about something
more delicate more sophisticated than
him dying seems to be a nod to how
unique he is when he says that in my
mind he's talking about the gate
builders who were all wiped out by a
similar attack he has something they
didn't have he can inhabit a body that
at least for now is immune to the goth's
attacks that's definitely fascinating
and it shifts directly to being
mysterious since he cuts out right after
he talks to trejo considering he's the
pob of the prologue we probably won't
get another peek behind the curtain
unless there's an interlude or something
like that and based on tanika's first
chapter it sounds like everyone's gonna
be searching for him and reacting to
whatever it is that he does it's
interesting and sweet that he came back
for teresa rather than the empire that
his connection to her that's what he was
thinking about in his love for his
daughter and her being threatened by
cortazar that's essentially what brought
him back i liked how they framed that
and found it curious after he came back
that he could sense her and could tell
that she was alright but chose not to
appear to her it makes me think that he
wasn't able to and if we think of the
investigator as a guide it's probably
because there's no active proto-molecule
on the rossi anymore trejo was on a
laconia ship that would have remnants of
proto-molecule built in it also makes
you wonder if his reaching out for her
might not also be related to amos's
seizure which i'm not really sure it
sounds cool but it could just as easily
be something he's doing in relation to
the adro diamond and the library because
at one point he thinks about his
connection from the quote i opened the
video with and there is mention of the
adro alvi kara and zan in the blurb on
the back of the book he's clearly
operating on a different level and i'm
excited to see where that goes
the prologue is the most intriguing
thing about this and the part that
promises something new but it's also
nice to slip back into the familiar with
the crew of the rossi they're on the run
so things are pretty uneasy and holden
might have achieved a new level in his
book opening ptsd which is really saying
something if you think back he's always
got something going on at the beginning
like eros or the ringgate station or
ellis and this time he's coming off
being imprisoned on laconia he was
separated from the crew for a long time
an entire book and all the parties
involved had to start to accept that
they'd probably never be reunited you
see naomi thinking about that in her
chapter how she mourned holden and how
she mourned the person she was with him
by her side how she wasn't ready for him
to come back and it's kind of that way
across the board the beginning felt
somewhat cinematic to me like watching a
movie as it introduces each character as
you get oriented with the world it's
trying to portray here what you get is
that the rossi is different though it
has all those familiar things like
holden going to the galley for coffee
but what's missing really starts to
stand out clarissa and bobby are both
dead jim is struggling to keep himself
out of crisis mode amos is a black-eyed
gray-skinned probably immortal
reanimated by the proto-molecule walking
corpse and they've got duarte's daughter
teresa on board
teresa is kind of a shield at least her
presence should stop any laconians from
destroying the ship outright but they
are chasing after her and none of the
crew want to end up in a position where
they would have to negotiate with the
empire there's a laundry list of reasons
for that at this point so they're forced
to keep moving and keep hiding in the
prologue you get the idea that laconia
is still powerful enough with the ships
it has left to threaten earth and mars
at this point they still have to follow
along with the empire the underground as
a sort of insurgent force rocked them on
their home planet and continued to
operate scattered amongst the systems
behind the ring gates elvi is still out
there trying to figure out more about
the romans and the goths and tanika is
tasked with going after duarte everyone
everywhere is worried about the goss
what the unknown aggressor's next move
will be the blurb continues as nearly
unimaginable forces prepare to
annihilate all human life holden and a
group of unlikely allies discover a last
desperate chance to unite all of
humanity with the promise of a vast
galactic civilization free from wars
factions lies and secrets if they win
but the price of victory may be worse
than the cost of defeat and there's
evidence of the unknown aggressors
fooling around with fundamental physics
with the changing of the speed of light
in relation to the last attack we also
know from a spoiler that tai and daniel
put out there that they are still
working on annihilating humans remember
the last thing that amos said in book 8
when holden asked him about the new
things he knows since he's been changed
one of the things i know is that they're
gonna kill everyone as far as tanaka's
chapter i like the characterization she
was a military badass in the tradition
of bobby who was clearly more
experienced and wiser than sing who
ended up dismissing her i liked the
twist in that of how she was there to
smooth his edges but he reacted badly
eventually screwing up everything this
new side of her makes her a lot more
interesting her tendency to get off on
breaking the rules behind the scenes
while still being a willing and
passionate adherent to the idea of
laconia it makes her feel like she might
have some unique takes on things that
could certainly come in handy i imagine
she'll come across the rossi in her
search for the high council but perhaps
in the end they'll have to work together
anyways
that idea of becoming is the thing that
kept jumping out at me setting the stage
with duarte's becoming something that's
probably going to be essential to the
conclusion after his being something
that was essential to the beginning of
setting up this dire situation in the
first place holden as jim you have to
wonder if they'll eventually switch the
heading on his chapters when he becomes
what the crew and humanity needs him to
be we know he's been on this nine book
journey to become what the writers need
him to be and that's something that
we're finally going to get to look at
amos is important as well i believe him
when he says he's still in there but can
only guess that his current condition
will prove to be essential in some way
with whatever they're up against
plus they have a dog now flying around
in space on the rasanante that's fun and
i think that's a good place to leave it
let me know what you think about these
sample chapters in the comments and what
you think is going to happen i did see a
post about reading beyond these chapters
and i did read one more tanaka chapter a
different pov and one of either naomi or
holden's i can't remember i thought it
was as far as it went and that it's
fixed but then i heard that you can
actually see the end if you mess around
with it i don't want to know what
happens nobody else wants to know what
happens if you did that i don't want to
hear about the ending without reading
everything that leads up to it so please
do not spoil things in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon